Heat.
[Music]
[Applause]
Heat. Heat. Heat.
[Music]
[Applause]
Hello and welcome to another episode of
What's Up Prof. Hello,
Walter. Dead silence. Dead silence. It's
a sound of silence. Hello, Martin. How
you doing? Well, I was worried there for
a while. Why didn't you think I lost my
voice? I didn't know what's going to
come now. Oh, well, I hope something
proper comes out of all of this cuz we
have a very important topic. Yes. And
maybe just to tell the people this the
how this got together is I don't think
people
realize how busy these guys keep us.
Yes. Because they everything happens in
the last moment and uh some somewhere
between midnight and the morning you
have to put it together right in the
night season. in the night season.
Well, it's Would you want to say
something about the backdrop and then we
can open with prayer? Well, let's just
talk a little bit about the backdrop. I
think uh the subject matter is a very
serious
one and we have titled it the second
siege. This is of course a reference to
the siege of
Jerusalem and the siege was around the
city and antitically inside the city
should be those that keep the
commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus. Correct. So this is the the
conflict that we're going to talk about
and it's very
fascinating. But before we get there, we
first have a little story to tell and
then we'll pray. Okay, that's good.
Yeah. Yes. Because this is just an
aside. Yes. Tell us about uh what's on
the screen there at the moment. Okay.
So, people will see that this is the new
pope, Pope Leo the 14th and we were busy
putting together this presentation and
this video occurred and we thought wow
this will be very interesting. It will
be a powerful one to include. And then I
don't know how it happened but we saw
another video made by the same YouTube
channel. And in the description there
was stood that this is not real. It is
fiction and it's done with AI. So we
went and rewatched this video and lo and
behold it's made with AI. Uhhuh. So
maybe it's very important for people to
realize. Well this was a speech. Tell us
about the speech between the parties. So
it was the president of Bikina Faso.
They've made quite a few videos it seems
now of this guy. Yes. And he wrote
apparently wrote a letter to the new
pope and the pope was addressing all
these issues about colonization in
Africa. Yes. And the speech left people
speechless. Yes. And they were
overwhelmed. And the video already has
over a million views. Almost a million
views. And and the majority of people in
there are convinced. Convinced this is
real. Even atheists, Muslims or of all
people, they say I'm a Muslim, but this
is an amazing speech. It's amazing. Now,
the speech is AI generated. But whether
the speech had influence from other
sources, we won't know. Uh it's very
well done, very well
written. There are some twists in it
that we would probably have to look at
from a not only from a political but
also from a religious aspect and say
whether this is legit or not. But we're
not dealing with that. The fact of the
matter is this video was AI generated
and is not based on fact. That's it. And
then what also is important, it took us,
it wasn't immediate that we could see
that this is AI. Maybe a lot of people
that know AI would say, "Oh, but you
should have seen this." It depends on
where it happens. So, and it is written
there in the small print, but you have
to really look for it. And most people
don't. They just take it at face value.
So maybe that's a real wakeup call and a
warning for to our viewers. They take
the picture or the actual footage of him
speaking, but they change what he's
saying and put words in his mouth. And
the important thing to remember is they
can do that with anyone. Yes, that's
what we want people to realize. So they
could do it with you and they could do
it with me. So tomorrow I could come
onto the screens and say that I distance
myself from everything that I have
proclaimed so far and it's all false.
Yeah. Meanwhile, that could be AI
generated and very far from the
truth. So people must make sure that
they don't swallow hook, line, and
sinker everything that seems real in the
media. Let's play a little piece of this
just to get the feel and then we'll move
on to our I believe much more important
issue to his excellency President Ibraim
Truff, president of the sovereign nation
of Burkina Fazo, son of the African soil
defender of his people. May grace and
peace be multiplied to you through
wisdom, courage and truth. I received
your letter not as a political
communicate nor as a demand echoing
through diplomatic channels. I received
it as a cry of the sole powerful
principled and painful. So now Martin
now that we have dispensed with that and
said be careful what you watch and make
sure that the sources are
legitimate and that the information is
legitimate. We will move to our lecture
today titled the second siege and for
this we need prayer. Amen. Let's
pray. Our father in heaven we are so
thankful that we can do these
discussions especially in a time such as
this. We ask that you now with a special
blessing please enlighten our minds be
here with the Holy Spirit and be with
everybody that's watching this in Jesus
name. Amen.
Amen. Now, people might be inclined to
say, "Oh, there they go again shouting
wolf." Now, that might be so, Martin. We
don't know, right? We're not
prophets. We cannot foretell the future.
We can just do the best we can with the
information at our disposal.
And we can look at
prophecy and try to find the
correlations. And if the correlation is
very fitting and uh above reasonable
doubt, then I think uh it is necessary
to raise an alarm. I think so too.
That's there's a difference between just
crying wolf and raising an alarm. Yes,
I'm sure there's a little bit of a
difference because the one is the intent
is bad. Yes. Raising an alarm is
caution. Yes. So, and uh if it wakes up
people, all the better. So, let us have
a look at this second
siege and antiypically against those
that keep the commandments of God and
the faith of Jesus because that's what
it says in the book of Revelation. Yeah.
that the devil was wroth with them and
went to make war with the remnant of
their
seed. Well, let's jump right into
it. There were two sieges before the
destruction of Jerusalem in 17
AD. And if we go to the historic
sources, no matter which ones we quote,
you will find that history confirms that
this is exactly what happened.
If you go back into the Old Testament
times when Nebuchadnezzar destroyed the
temple the first time, there was also a
first incursion where he took away the
captives, the king's family. Daniel and
his friends were taken captive and then
there was a a siege which destroyed
eventually which ended in the
destruction of Jerusalem.
So fast forward to the time of
destruction of the second
temple. Jesus had said that it would be
destroyed, that not one stone would be
upon
another. And he had warned his disciples
that when you see the abomination of
desolation spoken of by the prophet
Daniel, now we did a whole WhatsApp prof
about that and I think it was
providential by the way. It's never
planned. No, we never plan these things
but uh we pray about them of course and
I believe that the the Holy Spirit
impresses one as to you know what should
you be talking about in the times that
we are living in.
So there were two sieges. Let's have a
look at those two
sieges. We're quoting from the great
controversy and that can be of course
corroborated with other historic
sources. So this is just our
choice. Not one Christian perished in
the destruction of Jerusalem. Christ had
given his disciples warning and all who
believed his words watched for the
promised sign when ye shall see
Jerusalem trumpets with
armies. That's the parallel text in
Luke. Jesus said Jesus then know that
the desolation thereof is nigh.
Then then let them which are in Judea
flee to the mountains and let them which
are in the midst of it depart
out. So that was the
warning. After the Romans under Cestius
had surrounded the city, they
unexpectedly abandoned the siege when
everything seemed favorable for an
immediate attack.
So Cus arrived with the army. They were
going to take
Jerusalem and then he received some
message and he departed. That's
history. So what happened then? The
besieged despairing of successful
resistance were on the point of
surrender when the Roman general
withdrew his forces without the least
apparent reason. that God merciful
providence was directing events for the
good of his own people. The promised
sign had been given to the waiting
Christians. And now an opportunity was
afforded for all who would to obey the
Savior's
warning. So events were so overruled
that neither Jews nor Romans should
hinder the flight of the Christians.
Now, we don't have to read it all. We
can summarize some of this. The Zealots
thought, well, this is their great
opportunity to get rid of the Romans
once and for all. Okay. So, the Zealots
are the they are the Hebrews that were
intent on getting rid of the Roman yoke.
Okay. So, they were the ones there were
some disciples that were also zealots.
Yes. Remember they had this notion in
their mind that the nation would rise
and rule over everyone and everything
seemed reversed. Everybody was ruling
over them and that didn't fit into their
theological picture. And so they
attacked the Roman army as it was
retreating and started wiping out the
Roman army from the rear.
Now, the Romans managed to disentangle
themselves and get in way, but with
heavy
losses. You can imagine that didn't go
down well, right? Especially not with
Rome. No, they were
exceedingly
angry. And so, they must have been
planning to take revenge and to make
sure that this doesn't happen again.
Well, in that interim period, which was
a three and a half year period, the
Christians recognized that this army had
surrounded the place and now they had
withdrawn and that was their signal
according to what Jesus had said to flee
from Jerusalem. And seeing that the Jews
were so busy with the Romans, they never
even noticed what the Christians were
doing. Yeah. Because they thought, "Ah,
this is now our chance. this is our
opportunity to get the Romans. So they
forgot about the Christians and the
Christians all
escaped. So the siege was resumed three
and a half years later under the general
Titus.
The city was invested at the time of the
Passover when millions of Jews were
assembled within its walls. Their stores
of provision, which if carefully
preserved, would have supplied the
inhabitants for years, had previously
been destroyed through jealousy and
revenge and contending factions. And now
all the horrors of starvation were
experienced. A measure of wheat was sold
for a talent. And the people were so
hungry, Martin, they gnawed at their
belts and at their their shields because
there was just no hope. It was a
terrible destruction. But there's a big
warning in in this that the store of
provision was depleted. Yes. Yes. We
have to we have to take note of all of
these things. So history tells us that
thousands perished from famine and
pestilence and natural affections seem
to have been destroyed. Hundreds robbed
their wives, wives their husband.
Children would be seen snatching food
from the mouths of aged parents. They
were reminded of the words of Isaiah.
Can a woman forget her sucking child?
What had happened here? What does it
mean, Martin, that your house has been
left to you desolate? This is what
happens. They had rejected Christ and he
honored their choice. Yeah. So they were
no longer under his protection. But the
Christians had received a
warning and they left. And then that
terrible siege which probably ended on a
Sabbath when they burnt down the temple
and the gold melted and ran between the
stones and the army in order to get to
the gold turned over every single stone.
So the words of Jesus, not one stone
will remain upon another, were literally
fulfilled. But there's a very
interesting history associated with
this. Now let's just go to Ucius. He was
the historian of the time closest to
that period. So he gave the following uh
example. He
said that spiritual
Israel was the one that was saved from
the destruction. So how does he phrase
this? He said, "Then the spiritual seed
of Abraham fled to
Pella on the other side of Jordan where
they found a safe place of refuge and
could serve their master and keep his
Sabbath." Mhm. That's a very important
point this. Yeah. Why should he mention
the spiritual seed? Because today we
have dispensationalism
uh circulating amongst the churches that
there is a literal seed which is literal
Israel and then the church but the
church according to this theology will
be raptured away
and only the Jews will be associated
with the messianic kingdom down here
which is of course totally
unbiblical but it is the Jesuit doctrine
which seems to have taken hold amongst
the people. Yeah. The point is everyone
who is in Christ according to the
scripture is Abraham's seed and heir
according to the promise.
And it's very interesting that he says
that they not only found safe haven, the
spiritual seed, the spiritual Israel, in
other words, those that were in Christ
had accepted him as the Messiah, but
also that they could continue to keep
the
Sabbath. Now, we'll we'll go further
into that. So, that's history. So, we're
we're quoting.
So if we actually go and have a look at
Pella, the present Pella today, of
course, the ruins of the ancient one are
just that, ruins, an archaeological
site. So this is the place that they
fled
to. And archaeology has revealed that
the Sabbath, the seventh day Sabbath by
the Christians, yeah, was kept there in
Pella until the 4th century. that that
is um negating quite a bit of what
people say that in the first century
they already started keeping Sunday and
all of this. The disciples even kept
Sunday although there's nothing of that
nature in the Bible whatsoever. But
where does this Sabbath issue come in
with us? So let's have a look at this
prophecy again. We dealt with it
remember in a whole what'ss up prof.
Jesus warned his disciples about the
coming destruction of Jerusalem. And of
course this prophecy being in Matthew 24
has a double
application because the disciple
happened to ask him uh give us the signs
not only of the destruction of Jerusalem
but also of your coming. True. True. So
there's a double application. Right. So
let's have a look at those two verses
again just for clarity's sake. Matthew
24:15. When you therefore shall see the
abomination of desolation spoken of by
Daniel the prophet, stand in the holy
place, whosoever readeth, let him
understand. Then let them which be in
Judea flee into the mountains. So that's
your signal for flight.
All right. Now, what was this holy
place? We have to look at that. What was
this holy
place? And here we have Luke 21 which is
the parallel text and it gives a
different version of the same issue. And
when you shall see Jerusalem compassed
with armies, then know that the
desolation thereof is
nigh. Now the Bible here calls it the
abomination of desolation. And that's
the equivalent of the Roman army. Yeah.
That's it says though in the Bible.
Correct. All right. So when the Bible
talks about an abomination and we dealt
with this in a lot of detail, it means
idolatry. Yeah. The abomination of the
nations around were their pagan deities.
Now the Romans always marched under a
standard
and that standard was a pagan standard.
Now what was this special thing that was
going to happen when this standard and
this army which was an abomination
idolatry which would eventually lead to
the destruction Mhm. what was the
issue that was important there? What
happened when they fled to Pella? Very
fled to go and keep the Sabbath. They
fled to keep the Sabbath.
So when the Romans laid siege on the
city, they set up standards or banners
upon which were depicted their pagan
gods. Those standards were planted in an
area of ground around the city walls
known as the holy ground. Uhhuh. The
holy
place. This is not to be confused with
the holy place in the temple, which is
the first chamber. They weren't in
there. They were outside the walls.
Right. Yes. This was not they were
outside the walls. And this is the same
event that is found in the book of
Matthew. When you therefore shall see
the abomination of
desolation spoken of by Daniel the
prophet stand in the holy place. Whoso
readeth, let them understand. Then let
them which be in Judea flee into the
mountains. All right. Now let's let's
talk about this holy place. Why was it
called a holy place? Mhm. No, it it was
a few furlongs outside of the
city. Now, what was holy place about
that? Now, we have to go back into the
Bible to the time of Nehemiah.
And if you read the book of Nehemiah,
the very last reforms that were
introduced were Sabbath reforms.
And he noticed that the tradesmen were
coming into Jerusalem on the Sabbath day
and selling their wares.
And he rebuked the people because this
was desecrating the Sabbath day.
And so he cleared an area around the
city and commanded that any person or
any tradesman that should enter into
that space on a Sabbath day would be
dealt with. Okay?
And so they were afraid of what he was
doing to them because he was going to
stop this entirely, this desecration of
the Sabbath. And he cleared
it. And he cleared it for the purpose of
keeping the
Sabbath. So the holy ground around the
city was holy for Sabbath consecration.
Are you with me? Yes. Very interesting.
Okay. So, what is this idol which is an
abomination that will come in and
desecrate because it says it will be
standing in a place where it should not.
Yeah. So, that is doing exactly what it
should not be doing in that holy place.
Doing what it should not be doing in
that holy place surrounding Jerusalem.
What are they doing?
They are violating a precept.
So it has to do with the Sabbath issue.
Yeah. Because that was what the holy
place was all about. So let's look at
that a little bit further.
We have a statement here in testimonies
volume 5 which says the time is not far
distant when like the early disciples we
shall be forced to seek a refuge in
desolate and solitary places as the
siege of Jerusalem by the Roman armies
was the sign for flight to the Judean
Christians. So the assumption of power
on the part of our nation in the decree
enforcing the papal Sabbath will be a
warning to
us. It will then be time to leave the
large cities preparatory to leaving the
smaller ones for retired homes in
secluded places amongst the
mountains. So apparently there's going
to come a parallel event. Yeah. Yeah.
There was the first siege under
Cestius. They withdrew. This gave God's
people a period of time in which to
regroup and to as far as possible remove
themselves from danger. Then would come
a second siege which would parallel what
happened in the siege of Titus from
which there was no escape. Yeah. Right.
It's a very serious very serious. Now in
1897 in a letter in letter 90 the
following statement was written. The
Protestant world have set up an idol
Sabbath past tense. Yeah. In a place
where God's Sabbath should
be and they are treading on the in the
footsteps of the papacy. For this
reason, I see the necessity of the
people of God moving out of the cities
into retired country
places. Interesting statement. Yeah.
Here's another statement in the Review
and Herald. So it will be again.
But it is over the seventh day Sabbath
that the battle will be fought. The
authorities of this world will rise up
in their pride and power to make laws to
restrict religious liberty.
They will assume a right that is God's
alone and like Nebuchadnezzar will think
that they can force the conscience which
only God can
control. Even now they are making a
beginning. That was in 1898.
And this they will carry forward till
they reach a boundary over which they
cannot step. Then God will interpose in
behalf of his loyal commandmentkeeping
people.
So the destruction of Jerusalem is a
type of the destruction of the world.
Remember? Yes.
So let's look at these two sieges,
Martin, in a little bit more detail. I
believe this is a very important point,
very important presentation. I think the
more you go into this, the more people
will realize this is serious, really
serious. We're in a very serious
position.
The pressure for Sunday law has come
past
tense and is coming future
tense. Right? We can see that that which
we have been talking about for the last
35 years, this law causing the Sunday to
be exalted and making human inventions
take the place of God's holy day is now
being fulfilled.
So that happened in the past
but it's not
referring to
Jerusalem. It was a closer a a a nearer
past. It it is uh talking about the
antitype. Yeah.
So in 1897 we read this statement. The
decree enforcing the worship of this day
is to go forth to all the world. In a
limited degree, it has already gone
forth. So, past tense. Yeah. In several
places, the civil power is speaking with
the voice of a dragon just as the
heathen king spoke to the Hebrew
captives. So, something has already
happened and something is going to
happen. There was a first siege and
there was a second
siege. So, when did something happen?
Let's look at that. And who was ruling
at the time and who were the powers that
be? Well, in 1888, the world witnessed
the first
siege. And that was when Congress
introduced what was called the Blair
Sunday Rest Bill.
And it stated to secure to the people
the enjoyment of the first day of the
week, commonly known as the Lord's day
as a day of rest and to promote its
observance as a day of
worship. Introduced by Senator Blair of
New Hampshire, May 21,
1888. Referred to committee on education
and labor hearing on bill December 13,
1888.
Report of hearing, miscellaneous
document number 43, not reported out of
committee, etc., etc. It's legal
language. Proposing an amendment to the
Constitution of the United States
respecting establishment of religion and
free public schools. In other words,
church and state has to come together.
Yeah. Didn't Donald Trump just
say, "No, we're putting that aside."
Yeah. He said they probably would um
have legal action but Pam Goldie will
take care of that. No, that's right. All
right. Say order to lie on table later
referred to committee on education and
labor hearing on measure February 15 and
February 22,
1889 not reported CR etc. So in 1888
they tabled a Sunday law and they were
going to introduce it. Now interesting.
It was about a economic
fair that was representing not just the
United States but all the nations. Yeah.
They were all there taking part in the
fair. And the issue was should this fair
be able to operate also on a Sunday or
not? And they seized the opportunity to
say no, we're going to make a point of
it. Sunday is going to be a holy day and
we're going to make it a law. Yeah.
Okay. And those that were opposed were
already being arrested. So there was
prosecution already. There was
prosecution already. So they were so
convinced that they were going to do
this. So this was a siege against those
that believed in freedom of conscience
and keeping the Sabbath. Now a man by
the name of Alonzo T. Jones who happened
to be an
Adventist and he together with another
man called uh E.J.
Wagner had just before that in a in a
great
issue laid very great emphasis on the
righteousness of Christ.
This is very important. Definitely it
works together. It works together. In
other words, that we are not saved by
our
works and that we are not saved by
keeping the law. Our righteousness comes
from Christ and Christ alone. And that
is our title to heaven and not our
works.
This is totally independent of this
Blair Bill. When the Blair Bill was
introduced, Alonzo T. Jones made a
magnificent
speech which was so
profound that the Blair bill actually
failed as a consequence. So he went to
Congress. Yes. He held the speech before
Congress and the Blair Bill failed and
the army basically retreated
in apparent defeat. But we know that in
the typical they were planning a second
siege, right? Yeah. Under Titus where
the destruction would be final. So
there's no third or fourth siege, a
second one. So what happens there after?
Now let's just go a little bit more into
detail as to what happened at that time.
At that time they organized an
organization that was called the Lord's
Day Alliance. Uhhuh. Okay. And this
Lord's Day Alliance was a an
organization that had to work amongst
the peoples and at various levels to
make sure that Sunday becomes recognized
as an official day of rest and that
this defeat or withdrawal will not
happen again.
It's interesting. So they made actually
a whole thing about the Lord's day. Yes.
with day called Sunday. But of course,
the Roman Catholic Church had defined
the Lord's day as Sunday. Yeah. Without
one word from the Bible claiming that
John in the revelation was envisioned on
the Lord's day. And they said it was
Sunday, but there's not a word that it
was Sunday in the Bible. And the only
place in the Bible where it defines what
the Lord's day is is in Isaiah chapter
58 where it talks about the Sabbath as
the Lord's day and making it honorable.
So the Bible knows only the Sabbath as
the Lord's day, but Rome just changed
it. We'll come to that. Okay. And now
they made this organization to defend
it, to work behind the scenes and in
public spheres to make sure that Sunday
becomes the recognized day of rest, a
legal day. So Martin, the Lord's Day
Alliance of the United States was
founded, of course, in
1888, very important year.
That year, representatives of six major
Protestant denominations met in
Washington to organize the American
Sabbath Union. This name was later
changed to the Lord's Day Alliance of
the United States. So this alliance has
been the one national organization whose
sole purpose is to
maintain and cultivate the first day of
the week as the time for rest, worship,
Christian education, and spiritual
renewal. And Martin, this comes straight
from the Lord's day alliance. So uh
we're not talking conjecture here. And
the date is very important. 1888 for
sure. It it always works like this. It
always works like that. History is very
precise and the devil always has a
counterfeit. Whenever there's something
going out, he counterfeits with
something else. Correct? So, let's go
back to these statements. In 1903
uh we read in country living the time
has come when as God opens the way
families should move out of the cities
the children should be taken into the
country parents should get as suitable a
place as their means will allow. So
Martin this must be after the first
siege which was
1888 and seeing that this was written in
1903. This is this interim period when
you see this happening where they want
to set up the idol Sabbath. Yeah. They
then make sure that you try and separate
yourself from the
cities. The Review and Herald 1906 says
this statement. We must show to the
world that we recognize in the events
that are now taking place in connection
with the national reform movement the
fulfillment of
prophecy that which we have for the last
30 or 40 years proclaimed would come is
now here.
They're setting up this issue. Yeah. the
standard is being now interestingly it's
not only in the United States where this
was being set up in the United States it
was very important because there was a
separation a legal separation of church
and state that it works more
underground in Europe it didn't work
underground no it worked publicly
so there you have also a Lord's day
alliance on many many fronts and it it
makes use particularly of the power of
the trade unions to enforce it. Capital
and labor must be the driving force. Now
we have to ask ourselves who introduced
those trade unions in order to push the
agenda. Right? Yeah. Okay. Always look
at the driving force.
All right. So, how is this going to
happen? Now, we don't have the answers.
We can't tell people how they should
distance themselves from the destruction
that is coming by distancing themselves
from city life. So, how do you deal with
this? Well, she says here, "For years,
we have been instructed that our
brethren and sisters, especially in
families with children, should plan to
leave the cities as the way opens before
them to do so. Many will have to labor
earnestly to help open the way." This is
important because I know already and
we've seen it recently. A lot of people
will be asking and sending questions
through. But when should we leave? How
should we leave? All of this. We should
leave already.
That is that is plain. That's number
one. If you can't do it yourself, let
someone else help you. If it's
impossible to leave, well then make it a
matter of prayer and let God take care
of that. and some people won't be able
to leave the cities then that becomes
God's problem and not our problem but we
should do what we can and when we can
all right now this becomes very
important as we see as we go along so we
also have an admonition let all things
be done decently and in order so there's
no panic rush involved here 1
Corinthians 14 said the messenger shall
not the cities be warned warned. Yes.
Not by God's people living in them, but
by them visiting them to warn them. So,
we're not to become uh exclusive. We're
not to become
monastic. We must deal with these
issues. We must talk to the people. We
must have churches. We must have
campaigns. But we don't have to live
directly in the cities. There will be
violence. Are we already seeing violence
in the cities? I mean, Martin, just look
at the news. You're not safe to be in
big crowds in the city because next
moment a car comes plowing through on
purpose and runs you down. How many
cases of that have we witnessed in the
last time? How many mass shootings have
we witnessed? How much more evidence did
you need that the cities are no longer
safe places to live in? No, I think it's
you've people have known for many years.
I mean they this warning was already in
and it doesn't mean you have to live far
from it. No, you can just live outside
but don't take part in in those issues
in the city. Separate yourself. You see
some there are some places where it's
difficult or where it is dangerous to
live on farms like for instance in South
Africa but it's the same in the city. So
there's no safe place. There's no safe
place. So as God opens up the way uh
congregate together, work together, make
plans and don't ask us, ask God. Amen.
So year long there will be such strife
and confusion in the cities that those
who wish to leave them will not be able.
We must be preparing for these issues.
This is the light given. Even more
important, let us not forget this
precious promise from the pen of
inspiration. God will help his people to
find homes out of the cities. That is
the issue. All right, this is the
background. Now, people will say, it's
been so
long. You know, Jesus said the city was
going to be destroyed. That was in his
lifetime. It was only destroyed in 70
AD. Yes.
Noah Mhm. said the world is going to be
destroyed. And he started building an
ark. And he built for 120 years. And the
people said he was nuts. Exactly. He was
crazy. The whole time they probably
said, "Look at this fool." Yes. He It's
It's already 100 years and he's still
building. Yes. And 120. And then finally
the animals all stood started moving in.
They have said, "Wow." The scientists
said probably an electromagnetic pulse.
Yeah. A solar flare. Solar flare
affected these animals. Let's see what
happens. And when they were shut in,
they said, "H, nothing's happening for 7
days." And then it was too late.
Yeah. The door was
shut. Interesting, Martin. The wrappings
in the Fox Sisters, the first real
manifestation of spiritism happened in
1844. Yeah. But their organizations to
further the aims of occultism were
actually founded in
1888. 1888 the occult societies teach
that the new dispens dispensation has
begun. So here we have an article called
the great work the coming masters and
it's from Quakertown and it says we
accept this fact that the following the
drama in the heavens the new
dispensation which had its actual
beginning in
1888 will have reached its apex as has
the old and what a savior a great leader
one greater than any before will be
possibly already born. Now, we've had
lots of these guys. Yeah. And there's
one now in the Middle East who claims to
be the Messiah of the Muslims and the
Jews and the
Christians. And people are flocking to
him in their thousands for
some incomprehensible reason. Because
Jesus said when you hear him babbling
over there or babbling over there then
don't go because he will come like
lightning is visible from the east to
the west. Right.
Interesting just the date. So 1888 we
had a first siege.
Yeah. Now what also happened in 1888?
Well, there was a revival, a worldwide
revival, and Christianity was being
swept up in this movement. Dwight Moody
and at Pearson were leading great
revivals. The student volunteer movement
of the foreign missions was organized
and there was an occult explosion all at
the same time. M. Now, doesn't the Bible
say that uh the dragon religion will
also be prominent in the last days?
Yeah, absolutely. It will be it's going
after the the remnant of the seed. So,
it wants to destroy it not only
physically but spiritually as well. And
the Sunday debate was raging not only in
the churches, not only in the Lord's day
alliance, but in the political sphere.
and Adventists were actually being
persecuted for Sunday violation and some
were placed in chain gangs while
miracles and healings were taking place
amongst believers all around. It's a
very interesting period in
history. Now for the next point Martin,
who was the pope who ruled in this time
period and what influence did he use to
further the events? Yeah. Because there
are a number of things that were
important. capital and labor had to come
on board because they were the ones that
through their power would be able to
enforce the ideologies that were coming
from Rome. Yeah. And packed in there
nicely packaged was the Sabbath issue as
well. Now the pope that was ruling at
that time was Pope Leo I 13th.
That's just coincidence.
Uh I'm sure it was
Martin. And he was the pope that reigned
during the industrial
revolution. And he was the pope that
wrote the
encyclical Novarum.
Now if people would go back to what we
said under total onslaught many years
ago they will remember that rerum
novarum played a very prominent role in
those lectures because this is the basis
Martin for the church's teaching on
social justice and rights and duties of
capital and labor. It is
the
defining
encyclical and Pope Leo is the
one that wrote it. Yeah. Under his
guidance, the trade unions were formed.
Uhhuh.
And I'm sure that the Jesuits
infiltrated and the Knights of Malta and
all their other knights, the Knights of
Columbus and who they all are
infiltrated all of those movements if
they didn't found them directly.
And this was the driving force in order
to have a lever to force government to
ensconce that which was their doctrine
but not biblical. Yeah. You know what's
interesting,
Martin, is that Pablio I 13th in Rum
Novarum came out very strongly against
communism and socialism. Okay. Yeah.
Uh at the same time the Jesuits had
proclaimed quite openly that their
preferred form of government was
fascism. M mhm. Now, fascism was
government and industry in partnership
for community. That's the definition
besides all the other ho paloy and the
the screaming and the marching and the
you know the crazy stuff that goes along
with it. The basis is it's also a form
of
socialism and it uh it allows for
private property. Mhm. But under certain
conditions and this is very important
that we understand this. It's always
that's how Rome works. You it's like
freedom of speech and freedom of
religion. Correct. It is but under what
they say. You have to read the fine
print in order to ascertain what really
is going on. And for that we really have
to go back all the way to the beginning
of the conflict in heaven. But we'll
come to that in a second. So let's just
go to Rum Novarum again. This is his
encyclical
uh on capital and labor and the
introduction says to our venerable
brethren the patriarchs, the primates,
the archbishops, the bishops and other
ordinaries of places having peace and
communion with the apostolic sea, rights
and duties of capital and labor.
Their point six is for every man has by
nature. Remember that they base their
morality on natural law and not on the
Bible which is very dangerous. Every man
has by nature the right to possess
property as his own. That sounds very
gratifying. One is relieved because
under communism you don't have that
right. No. So communismism was the
extreme. It it was actually also created
by the Jesuits, right? And it all
happened round about
1844 and it was the Hegelian dialectic
in order to push you in another
direction. So this pope distanced
himself from communism and even from
hardcore socialism. All right. So let's
go further into this encyclical and see
what it
says. So he reigned from 1879 to 1903.
So 1888 is slap bang in that papacy in
regard to the church. Her cooperation
will never be found lacking be the time
or the occasion what it may be. and she
will intervene with all the greater
effect in proportion as her liberty of
action is more
unfettered. Let this be carefully taken
to heart by those whose office it is to
safeguard the public
welfare. Now she was feted
which means she couldn't move like she
wanted to move because of the separation
of church and state.
So where she could move, she moved. And
here she moved in another way. So she
created levers in order to have a little
bit moreh space of movement. Right? And
this encyclical was written in
1891 in the 14th year of our capital.
Uhhuh. Now remember that the papacy
claims to be deity. Yeah. She takes the
place of God on earth.
So all the prerogatives of God she
claims in her own writings are her
prerogatives as well. And all the titles
ascribed to God and to Jesus she
ascribes to herself.
Now what let's just unpack that a little
bit.
God when he created
humanity
said I will give you eternal life on
condition that you obey my commands.
Yeah, that is the
condition. If you break the
condition or do not want to be part of
the condition, I'll take my life back
that I have given you. You cease to
exist. The day you eat of it, you will
surely
die. And God created man and put him
into a garden which he planted for whom?
For man. For man. the most beautiful
place
imaginable. And he said, "This I will
give
you. This will be your place. You can be
happy here on
condition that you keep my commandments
and obey my word. If you
don't, I will take my life back." And
that means you die.
Well, some people will say, "Then God is
actually killing you." No, he's not
actually killing you. He's allowing your
choice. Yes. And he's saying, "Okay, you
don't want the condition. Therefore, you
don't want the life. Therefore, I'll
take it back." So, in a sense, you do
die. Now, people say, "That's not fair.
I want to do what I want." But God was
fair from the beginning. Is it? That's a
condition. That's a condition.
If I don't know how you can say it's
unfair. No. And if you love me, you will
keep my commandments. And if you say you
love me and you don't keep my
commandments, then he says, then you're
a liar. Yeah. And you don't have the
truth. Right. That's just plain
biblical. That's biblical. So the devil
says, "Excuse me, no, I will give you a
wonderful life."
It's interesting. He doesn't say, "I'll
give you eternal life." Nope. All
right. Kingdoms. So in his definition of
being saved,
according to the
Jesuits, their definition of being saved
is to live a truly human life. Yeah.
That's ridiculous because it's a very
short period. Whereas God's is eternal.
But and nobody sees that. Yeah. That's
where the problem comes in. All right.
All you can see is here. that needs
spiritual eyesol. Correct. So he says,
"All right, I'll give
you a very human life, a happy life, but
you have to do what I say." They go
further. God says, "Everything is mine."
Yeah. And I will give it to whom I
please. All the cattle on a thousand
hills are
mine. So Rome says, "No." Mhm. They're
mine.
And the Bible says that the dragon gave
the papacy its seat and power and great
authority. Now that dragon is the
devil. When he tempted
Jesus, didn't he take him to the
pinnacle and say, "All of these I will
give you." That's it. So then he did did
he claim ownership of them? Yes. You
can't give them to Christ. If he didn't
believe that he owns it, he couldn't
offer it to Christ. But you have a
condition. You have to worship me. Yeah.
Now that condition applies to today.
Yeah. You will have a truly human life
and be able to have everything that you
need and be happy and though although
you don't own it. No. On
condition that you worship me and obey
me. Yeah. So the two parties are
claiming the
same issue, right? God says, "I'm the
creator. I give you life on condition,
and I'll give you an
eternity of
possession." The devil says, "I am the
one who owns everything. It belongs to
me. You will worship and obey me or I
will disown you." Yeah. What happened in
the Middle Ages? If you went against
Catholicism, you were disowned. You were
disowned. And then if you didn't come in
line, you went to the rack. They
tortured you to make you change your
mind. And if you didn't, you were burnt
at the stake. You were punished as a
heretic. Uh-huh. All right. Now, let's
go carefully into this. This might take
a while. Yeah. But it is very important
because we are heading for the second
siege. In article 22 or point 22 of
rerum novarum the pope pope Leo I 13th
quotes Thomas Ainus.
And Thomas Akinus is this Catholic saint
that is quoted not only by Pope Leo but
all the subsequent popes. Yeah. and the
previous
ones. It states here, "It is lawful,
says St. Thomas Ainus, for a man to hold
private property and is also necessary
for a carrying on of his human
existence."
But if the question be asked, "How must
one's possessions be used?" The church
replies without hesitation in the words
of the same holy doctor. Man should not
consider his material possessions as his
own but as common to all so as to share
them without hesitation when others are
in
need. So here's a little proviso
right now. Let's just go to canon law
and see what that entails. According to
canon law, the control of all property
of the Roman church state belongs to the
pope, its supreme emperor. Oh, that's
why he could draw the map of South
America and say, "All right, this
portion of South America, we'll call it
Brazil. I'll give to my faithful
stewards Portugal
administer
it. Go and take over the country."
Strange they didn't call them
colonizers. No.
And this portion of South America, we'll
give that to my faithful steward and
servant Spain and let's call it
Argentina. So various portions were
given either to Portugal or to Spain and
they were there to control it. And
nobody is saying that they're colonizers
and must go back home. Yeah. Nobody.
Just for interest sake. All right. John
Robbins says in his uh book
ecclesiastical megalomania, the Roman ch
Catholic doctrine of private property is
echoed in the 19th century communist
slogan from each according to his
ability to each according to his need.
So need makes the property common. So if
I have need, I can squat on your
property. Yeah. or if I have need, I can
actually occupy your empty building
because you're not occupying it and you
won't get me
out. You you try and do that in London
or anyone where else if somebody has
squatted in your property, it's very
difficult to do under the law. And
Thomas Aina in his Suma theologica also
wrote because the goods of some are due
to others by natural law. There's no sin
if the poor take the goods of their
neighbors. Martin this is directly
against God's commandment. Yes, that's
theft. In cases of need, he says all
things are common property. So there
would seem to be no sin in taking
another's property for need has made it
common.
If you live in South Africa, for
example, you will know exactly what that
means. Yeah. And why the law enforcement
agencies are basically handcuffed and
can do nothing about it. He continues to
say, not only is such taking of
another's property not a sin, it's not
even a crime.
So I can walk into a supermarket, walk
out with it, and 90% of the time, nobody
does
anything except the prices go up. Yeah.
It is lawful for a man to sucker his own
need by means of another's property by
taking it either openly or secretly. I
don't even have to come at night. I can
just can get out of my way. This is
mine. Nor is this properly speaking
theft and robbery. It's not theft
properly speaking to take secretly and
use another's property in a case of
extreme need because that which he takes
for the support of his life becomes his
own property by reason of that need. In
a case of like need, a man may also take
secretly another's property in order to
sucker his neighbor in need. So I walk
into your house and you have three
televisions. I don't have one. I'll take
one. I need it.
But I know that my pal also needs one.
So I'll take the other one as well. And
if you're lucky, I'll leave you one. And
if not, I'll leave you nothing and you
can go and buy another one. And it's not
a crime and it's not a sin because I
really need it. I also want to watch the
soapy.
I'm being sarcastic now, but this is
exactly what the reality in the world
is. Well, this is in certain portions
it's really enforced like in our
country. In our country, this is
absolute law. So we perceive it as
racism. Yes. But actually we are
fighting against canon law. That's how
important is that? Canon law will be the
law that's enforced all over the world.
Yes. So let's just make sure. Canon 1254
says the following. The Catholic Church
has an innate right to acquire, retain,
administer, and
alienate temporal goods in pursuit of
its proper ends independently of civil
power. The church has an innate right to
require from the Christian faithful
whatever is necessary for the ends
proper to it.
So the church has the right to do it and
it gives that right ipsay facto to the
government. So when the government says
we're going to confiscate the land
without compensation, they're actually
acting within canon law. Exactly. And we
must make that very clear that that law
has been written into our country. It's
written. It's there. But this is against
Protestants. Yes, this is against
Protestants. and they're labeled
colonizers
and they have to get out. So this is
very interesting. Let's just continue
this study.
Let's take the next popes. This is a
very important encyclical. So the trade
unions are created the means the lord's
day alliance and within that document
rum novarum Sunday plays an extremely
important part. Let's see how it
progresses. John Paul 2
uh expression of his
1987 encyclical on social concern
expands on rerum novarum. He says so
himself.
It is necessary to state once more the
characteristic principle of Christian
social doctrine. The goods of this world
are originally meant for all. This is
now John Paul speaking. Remember the
Catholic Church has time.
It plans over decades and centuries and
millennia. So every one of these
encyclicals is a move in a particular
direction. It's just creeping towards
the final thing that they want to
implement. Correct. The right of private
property is valid and
necessary but it does not nullify the
value of the principle. Private property
in fact is under a social mortgage.
It doesn't belong to you. Yeah. It has a
social function
which means that it has an intrinsically
social function. He says it himself.
Yeah. Based upon and justified precisely
by the principle of universal
destination of goods. You may accumulate
it so that others may have
it. You can build fences as much as you
like and put electric fences around your
house. This is the fact of the matter
and all of the periods in history you
can see like even communism what was the
main thing take away property. Yes.
Because it's lawful according to what?
According to them. So let's continue
this because this is getting very
interesting. He goes further in his
laborum exense. All goods
includes not just goods found in nature
but manufactured goods as well. So not
what's on your fruit trees. I can take
those for sure because I need them. I'm
hungry. He declared that all men must
have access to those goods which are
intended for common use. Both the goods
of nature and manufactured goods. I need
a car. Yeah.
So hi Jack. Yeah. I hijack it, right?
And I take it. And I take it because I
need it. I need it. And by the way, I
think my buddy needs one, too. So, I'll
take the other car as well. This is
basically what is happening worldwide in
the
world. All right, let's move on and go
to John Paul II's Gaudium at Space. This
is one of his encyclicals. If one is in
extreme necessity, he has the right to
procure for himself what he needs out of
the riches of others. Isn't that exactly
what Thomas Aus said? Yeah. Didn't Rum
Novarum quote him? Yeah, this is a it's
actually it's eyeopening. It's eye
opening. Since there are so many people
prostrate with hunger in the world, this
sacred council urges all both
individuals and governments to remember
the aforism of the fathers. feed the man
dying of hunger because if you have not
fed him, you have killed him. So that's
why they have this issue with the poor
and always especially the poor. They
don't really care about those that have
particularly since in many places it is
the Protestants that have that's why
they want to get rid of well they want
to get rid of the middle class. Yes. And
this is directly opposite to God's
model. Yes. because he gave land and you
couldn't even after if you did give it
away after a few years it should come
back to the region it must come back to
you and remember that Ahab
coveted neighbor's vineyard right and
then he wouldn't give it to him and Ahab
was
sulking and so Jezebel said to him
what's the matter with you I'll give it
to
you and she had never got killed Yeah.
And said there, go and take it. Now, if
you go to the book of Revelation, then
Jezebel becomes a symbol of the church
of the Middle Ages, of the Catholic
Church, who led the people into sun
worship, dear Solace, the day of the
sun, and she has the right to kill
Nabbot to give it to the king. So, in
other words, the the Catholic Church
says, "It's fine. You can take it." And
this is exactly what we're reading in
their encyclicals.
Then it's interesting that Pope John
Paul II wrote a long ex cyclical called
deas
dominy. The whole encyclical is on the
importance of Sunday and why it should
be a law.
Now I'm only going to read a small
portion of this
encyclical and it says finally it should
not be forgotten that even in our own
day work is very oppressive for many
people either because of miserable
working conditions and long
hours especially in the poorer regions
of the world or because of the
persistence in economically more
developed societies of too many cases of
injustice exploitation of man by and
went through the centuries. She
referring to the Catholic Church made
laws concerning Sunday rest. The church
had in mind above all the work of
servants and workers. Really, Martin,
she couldn't care less. She only cares
about herself because she owns
everything. Yeah. Certainly not because
this work was any less worthy when
compared to the spiritual requirements
of Sunday observance, but rather because
it needed regulation
to tighten its to lighten its burden and
thus enable everyone to keep the Lord's
day holy. Now look what he says in this
matter. My predecessor Pope Leo I 13th
in his encyclical Rum
Novarum spoke of Sunday rest as a
workers's right which the state must
guarantee. So Rum Novar is about capital
and labor and about
Sunday sacredness.
Pope John Paul this takes this issue all
the other popes as well by the way and
further this issue and nobody notices
what's happening.
No, but they won't because
unfortunately most are keeping this a
day. In any case, they're on board with
us. So 67 in his encyclical, therefore
also in the particular circumstances of
our time, Christians will naturally
strive to ensure that civil legislation
respects their duty to keep Sunday holy.
Is he asking for a Sunday law? Yes, he's
asking for it, right? Sure. civil
legislation. Did Donald Trump go and bow
down and go on his knees before a image
of John Paul II? Yeah. Inside of the
shrine, that big church that was built
for. What was he a Protestant doing?
Something like that. All right, Martin.
So, this is the point, right? Yeah. So,
let's build this up further.
He then had it enscconced in the
catechism of the Catholic
Church. It says in article 2188, "In
respecting religious liberty and the
common good of
all, even the destination of
goods, Christians should seek
recognition of Sundays and churches,
holy days as legal holidays. It's in the
catechism. Can't remove it." So that's
why you got holidays all over the world.
Holy days. Yes. Holy days. Yes. Most of
them are nonsense days, but they call
them holy
days. But this is the most profound
statement that he made. Yeah. This was
to the recorded in the Detroit News in
1998 where Pope John Paul II said, "A
person who violates the sanctity of
Sunday is to be punished as a heretic."
How were heretics punished? by death
with death. It's a death decree. Yeah.
So, he's actually asking for the death
penalty. Yeah. Well, that's it. Was
excommunicated or does the Bible say
it's going to happen? Yeah. Okay. Now,
Martin, we're not making this up. No,
this is all you're just putting it into
place because they hide everything.
Correct. Let's take Pope Francis, the
liberal pope. He writes
loadatus and says on Sunday our
participation in the eukarist has
special importance. Sunday like the
Jewish Sabbath is meant to be a day
which heals our relationship with God
with ourselves with others and with the
world. The law of weekly rest forbade
work on the seventh day so that your ox
and your donkey may rest. Is he
referring to that same day? For sure.
Because we must remember he's calling
Sunday. Yeah. The Sabbath. Now, Leo was
responsible for initiating all those
trade unions. Right.
Now, the Pope Francis was responsible in
introducing the climate issue. Yeah.
Churches together for the climate
Sunday. So, now they have another arm to
push their agenda. It has to do with
worship. We have to have climate focused
services. It has to do with
commitment, long-term actions to reduce
greenhouse gases. We have to speak up
about this issue and we need a climate
Sunday. So, this is how it came slowly
into the background and all of these
organizations are in place. It was just
another pull from to get a more broader
spectrum. Yes. of why we should keep
Sunday open and have a secular arm
rather than a purely religious arm.
That's it. Because now they can draw
more people are the ones that's not
religious an atheist maybe even all of
those people as well. So let's sum up
Martin. In
1888 there was a concerted effort to
bring about Sunday legislation.
It was in connection with a trade
fair. Capital and labor was the one that
was written by Rum Novarum or in Rum
Novarum by Pope Leo the 13th. And there
was a first siege, an attempt to put a
false Sabbath in the holy place
surrounding spiritual Jerusalem that was
dedicated to keeping God's Sabbath
sacred. M
so there was an army in that place
putting a pagan standard an
abomination in the place of the real
thing God's seventh day Sabbath. Yeah,
that's what the Bible teaches. That was
now 1888. This was correct. At the same
time, spiritualism is
formalized and then the subsequent
popes use Novarum as the basis for their
doctrine, building it out further,
expanding on the Lord's Day issue and
finally bringing it to the climate
issue. Now that pope is deceased,
Pope
Francis. And the question is, or was,
who would be the next pope? And what
name would he take? Well, we know by now
who the next pope is. The next pope is
Leo I 14th.
And he was chosen in May 2025. Right.
This is now in the last few days. Yeah.
and his name was Robert Pvost and he
comes from the United States having
lived in Peru. Very
interestingly he takes the church back
to its traditional roots. Now we claimed
in our previous WhatsApp prof that they
will probably go back to tradition. Yes.
Because the papacy doesn't change. No.
So this liberal period was a dialectic
Hegelian dialectic in order to create
enough opposition to bring it back to
the original. Right. Yeah. And to maybe
also grab some people along the way that
wouldn't normally have entered into this
church. Correct. So we suggested that it
will be a more traditional pope.
And how did he appear on the bank
balcony? Not like Francis in just the
white cloak. He appeared in the same
attire that
Benedict appeared beforehand. And
Benedict was the conservative,
ultra-conservative. And while he was
rating still as cardinal, he was the
head of the congregation of doctrine and
faith which had to make sure that the
church stays within its traditional
realm. And he's the one who said other
churches are no sisters of ours.
They are daughters and they have to
return to the
mother. So, Pope Leo who takes the name
Leo appears on the balcony wearing the
same traditional outfit that uh
Ratzinger wore. Now the question is why
did he take the name Leo? Now we don't
want to speculate. So, let's ask him why
he took the name Leo. And then let's ask
the Vatican and the Jesuits what they
think about it. Because remember,
Martin, Francis was a Jesuit. Yes. And
he appointed most of the cardinals that
actually chose the present pope. He was
the first and probably only Jesuit pope.
And the Jesuits know the agenda exactly.
They know where they're heading. And
whether they play a liberal role or a
conservative role, that's just eyewash.
They know the agenda. The rest is Jesuit
theater. So let's ask the Pope why he
chose the name Leo.
No, revolution industrial.
Now, isn't that fascinating, Martin? He
is Pope Leo the 14th because his
agenda is rarum novarum. Yes, Ramarum
under Leo was in the first industrial
revolution. Now we have another
industrial revolution where humanity is
threatened by AI that it can take away
your position. Interesting first little
video we showed there. But besides that,
you have all of these robots and things
taking the place of humanity. We need a
champion and the work must be guaranteed
to the worker and not to AI.
And many are worried how they're going
to put food on their table if AI takes
over. Now, we need the workers unions to
be involved in this. But there needs to
be capital and labor that is in harmony
with Rum Novarum
which also asked for Sunday
legislation. So Martin, if Pope Leo I
13th was the pope of the first
siege, is this the pope of the second
siege with the same name and the same
aim?
How can it be any other? It must
biblically it seems correct and even
visibly. Now in the
inauguration he definitely took the
church back to a more traditional
liturgy. Right. Definitely. And all the
traditionalists are happy. Even in his
uh
first mass? Yes. Didn't he do it halfway
in Latin? Yes. He also used a lot of
Latin. It didn't deal with full Latin
mass but it was a step in that direction
and the papacy was dedicated to Mary.
Yeah. Right on that very first day. And
that is very significant. So let's just
have a brief look at his
inauguration where of course he received
the fisherman's ring which is unique to
the pope. is especially made for the
reigning pope and should he die that
ring is destroyed and another one is
made and it becomes the papal seal. It's
also the ring that is kissed.
Has that got a spiritual thing going? Is
it is it um his spiritual authority? Oh,
it is a symbol of his authority. Yes. So
let's just look at the
inauguration which wasn't quite
traditional because he didn't take the
papal triar tiara the triple crown but
he took the lambkin as a shepherd and
the fisherman's ring. Pope Leo I 14th
was inaugurated with a ceremony in Rome
over the weekend which saw global
leaders come together to mark the
momentous occasion. The appointment of
Pope Leo I 14th sees a return to the
Catholic Church's roots. The new pope
confirmed in a meeting with the Vatican
diplomatic corps that the family is
founded on the stable union between a
man and a woman. This position is a far
cry from the former pope's blessing of
LGBTQIA plus relationships which is
sending liberal Catholics into a tail
spin. All right. So, one thing they said
is he's taking them back to the
traditions. So, we're going back to a
church that wants to be like it
was. Therefore, the wound is totally
healed. I read a comment that we are
contradicting ourselves because we said
the wound was healed when Mussolini gave
the papal states back to the papacy in
1929.
Yes, that was the beginning of the
healing of the wound because they got
political power back. But uh all the
aspects of their power weren't yet in
place. The healing of that wound is a
continuum until it is completely healed.
Yes. And the completion is that when
church and state is finally together and
legislation starts coming out. Correct.
And it's very important that he laid
emphasis on the family. Oh yeah. Because
in the encyclical of Pope Francis, the
family is associated with Sunday rest.
Yes. So we need Sunday rest,
synchronized day of rest in order to
further the needs of the family. So all
of this is
connected. So let's just go to some of
the articles. We don't have to read them
in all their glory, but the BBC asked
the question, who is Robert Post? the
new pope
Leo. And uh they write about
him that he chose the papal name and
why. And he says it signified a
commitment to dynamic social issues.
According to experts, the first pontiff
to use the name Leo whose papacy ended
in
461 met Attilla the Han and persuaded
him not to attack Rome. The last pope
Leo led the church from 1878 to 1903 and
he wrote of course rerum
novarum. So Martin these are the issues
and we've spoken about them. So this is
what the BBC had to say. I'm more
interested in what the Vatican has to
say. So what did the Vatican say? Leo I
13's time and our own. So this comes
directly from the Vatican news and it
says history professor Donald Prudllo
talks with Vatican news about Pope Leo
the 14's choice of names focusing on the
similarities between the challenges
fating facing Leo I 13th in the 19th
century and the world we find ourselves
in today. Then it talks about the
cardinal's meeting and the election of
the pope. And then they plainly state in
Vatican news just as the pope
said out of his own mouth
that he chose the name Leo mainly
because Pope Leo in his historical
cyclical rum Novarum addressed the
social question in the context of the
great industrial revolution. In our own
day, the church offers to everyone the
treasury of her social teaching. They
have another treasury which takes you
out of jail free, right? Out of
purgatory. And none of this is biblical.
But this is fascinating. So the Vatican
confirms that this is the agenda. And
remember, Sunday was part of the agenda
which the state must enforce. Yes.
according to John Paul II and Rum
Novarum. So again they reiterate that it
was because of Rum Novarum that they did
this because this is in defense of human
dignity, justice and labor and AI is of
course a threat. So they asked this Dr.
Prudllo a few questions. Can you talk a
little bit about what the pope told us
about the connection between the times
of Leo the 13th and our times? And he
says when he reigned during the first
siege of 1888, of course, he was the
pope. And it says uh Pope Leo I 14 has
told us why he chose this in particular
in reference to his great the charter of
Catholic social teaching the encyclical
rum Novarum. I cannot
believe that this was part of total
onsort a main part of it. It was a core
issue and what about this document rum
Novarum? What are they doing Martin?
They are Mhm. building this up into a
frenzy. Now, if we continue on this, he
made sure that he was going, this is Leo
the 13s, to with the wisdom of the
church, with the wisdom of St. Thomas
Ainus that he so strongly supported
through the practice of the rosary.
We saw this pope was very strong on the
rosary. He prayed. Exactly. Now there in
the rosary there are 10 hail Marys to
every
father. There is no other name whereby
we can be saved. There is no other
mediator. You cannot call her the co-
redemptric. You cannot call her the
mediatric. You cannot call her the
co-advocate of God because the Bible
says there's only one. Yeah. And the
Bible says that she was born under the
law. Yeah. under the condemnation of the
law. They claim no she wasn't no
immaculate. She was declared immaculate
at her birth. She
escaped the fallen nature of Adam. This
is not biblical.
It is paganism. So with regards to Rum
Novarum as you said it was part of the
context of a comprehensive view of
Catholic social teaching but subsequent
popes have picked up especially on rerum
novarum then he mentions Pope Pas then
he mentions Pope Paul I 6 then he
mentions Pope John Paul
II and he mentions Benedict and he
mentions all of them. So Martin, this
has been building up. Nothing nothing
falls between the cracks. It doesn't
matter if the pope is liberal,
conservative.
It's like politics. It doesn't matter
who wins is playing a role. And then
they say, Martin, that they've now
really come full circle. No, this is the
Vatican speaking.
So now, I want to make a point of this.
We've come full circle. Now
Martin, am I right when I say that when
you come full
circle, you come back to the place where
you started? Yeah. Then you've gone full
circle, right? Pope Leo the 13th. Mhm.
Did he start the Sunday movement? Yes.
Did he write it in his encyclical? Very
clearly. Did he start the trade unions
and the whole social doctrine? Mhm. And
was there an attempt to introduce Sunday
legislation and organize capital and
labor in accordance with his wishes?
Yes. Now, if we've gone full circle, are
we there again? That's what it says. Are
we then at the second siege?
I cannot see it any other. Martin, do
you realize that after the second siege
comes the destruction of the world? M
because a pagan standard will be set up
in the holy place where it should not
be. Yeah. It is an abomination that will
cause desolation and you will see it in
the advance of the Roman army and you
will hear the rumbling of the Roman
chariots. You will hear the rumbling.
And what is very important
is if you hear this, what did the
Christians do? those Jews, they fled
before the second siege. We have a very
short window.
All right, man. I'm always interested in
what the Jesuits themselves personally
have to say on on some of these issues.
So, let's go to the official mouthpiece
of the Jesuits in the United States,
America, the artic the
magazine. What's in a name? Why the pope
picked Leo the
14th? Well, Martin, he's echoing workers
rights. Pope Leo the 13th.
And one of the workers rights was Sunday
which the state must
guarantee. So again, they talk about the
encyclical verum novarum. So the Jesuits
are all on board with the same agenda.
Their agenda has never changed.
So we're talking about the social
encyclical rum Novarum and then they
mention all the others that were given
over the years afterwards. Quadraesimo
ano
magistra paras all dealing with the same
issues. And look at this loi and
fatelliti which both comes back to
Sunday. It doesn't matter whether it's a
liberal pope or whether it's not a
liberal pope. The agenda remains the
same. It is a means to an end. You know
what's interesting? This is just more
proof that Rome does not change. It
never
changes. So in our last one, we spoke
about project 2025.
Mhm.
and Sky News showed that every single
point that is written there in project
2025 has been imple implemented by the
Trump
administration through executive orders.
Yeah. So in other words, it didn't even
go through a process of vote. Right. And
then they asked the question, what's
next?
and they said, "Well, one of the issues
that's not addressed yet is the focus on
the family." Uh, did the present pope
say that was going to be his issue? Is
that what Ra Novarum and especially the
other ones like you said?
Yes. It's all about family and this. All
right. And it was about to restore the
American family. Now, didn't this
present pope say a family consists of a
man and a woman? Yeah. And that's the
unit of the family. Isn't that what
Trump said? Yeah. And then what is
necessary to create this unit? You need
synchronized time together which is
Sunday legislation.
Even the American dream like you
mentioned is inconstant the American
family which is owning property property
under a social mortgage. Right. So it's
not really yours.
And then let's listen to what they
further have to say. The Jesuits, this
is an article by Brett Mccclaclin and it
has the letters SJ behind it which means
society of Jesus. This is a Jesuit
writing. What is he saying? Recovering
the
Sabbath. Sunday observance as a
universal human right and civic
cooperationism.
And then there's a long article which we
won't go into. It says the paper
advances that the religion state model
of cooperationism would allow for civil
legislation to protect the
Sabbath.
Unfortunately, this is so unfortunate
for the Jesuits. The models of
separation or accommodationism have
predominated in the US since the Bill of
Rights. Why? Because they want to
separate church and state. However,
fortunately, cooperationist regimes such
as Germany recognizes the universal
common good present in religious
legislation. The cooperationist model,
cooperation with whom, mart? With Rome.
Oh. Oh. Is present in most European
countries.
It readily preserves democracy.
So there's no problem there. The
Judeo-Christian tradition may be the
source of advocacy for Sunday closing
laws. Yet a weekly rest from the economy
serves all citizens. Do they want Sunday
law? Oh, for sure. And they say actually
and thanks to the Christians, they are
doing it already for us. And thank you
Donald Trump for saying let's get rid of
this church and state separation
nonsense. Martin, we are living in the
second siege. And I believe so. I hear
the rumbling of the Roman
army. And I believe that the time is
near when this will have gone full
circle from the first siege to the
second
siege. Martin, could it happen that we
could be going
home? It could. two mansions prepared by
God himself for us if we keep the
commandments and have that banner and
the faith of Jesus rather than the faith
of paganism
where they cannot take your property.
Let's just make
sure because people will say you know
you you're stretching the metaphor. No,
no, no.
Rome issued a challenge in 2003 where
they stated, "Most Christians assume
that Sunday is the biblical approved day
of worship. The Roman Catholic Church
protests that it transferred Christian
worship from the biblical Sabbath,
Saturday, to Sunday, and that to try to
argue that the change was made in the
Bible is both dishonest and a denial of
Catholic authority.
If Protestantism wants to base its
teachings only on the Bible, it should
worship on
Saturday. Not me saying it, them saying
it. And why do they say it? Because they
say if you don't do it on a Saturday,
but do it on a Sunday, then you're
acknowledging them as the authority in
your life. Correct. And they call it
their mark of ecclesiastical authority.
The mark of the beast.
Martin, the holy
place was there to preserve the sanctity
of the
Sabbath. When you see that army
coming, Rome's
army, and if you look at the politics at
the moment and the Supreme Court, it's
all Rome. Yeah. And Protestants are just
bowing at the throne of the Caesar. Then
that Roman army will put its standard
its false Sabbath abomination
idolatry in the place where the other
one should be standing where it should
not says the
Bible and then they will enforce it and
God will intervene. God's people should
be out by then. And then the destruction
of the world will come by God's
outpouring of the final seven plagues.
That out that you just mentioned is not
only physical. No, it's spiritual.
getting your mind out of Babylon,
loosening yourselves from the idolatrous
practices mentally so that even if you
are trapped in the city, you are still
in the covering of God. And therefore,
let us read what Isaiah says. It says,
"Fear
not, for thou shalt not be ashamed,
neither be thou confounded, for thou
shalt not be put to shame, for thou
shalt forget the shame of thy youth, and
shalt not remember the reproach of thy
widowhood anymore." God is going to deal
with it. Jeremiah is to the point in 46
verse
27. Fear not thou, oh my servant Jacob,
and be not dismayed, O Israel, for
behold, I will save thee from a far off,
and thy seed from the land of their
captivity. And Jacob shall return and be
in rest Sabbath, and at ease, and none
shall make him afraid. We need not be
afraid. We need not believe that God is
going to forsake us. I will give my
angels charge over thee, says the
Bible. But I
believe we have the second siege. We
have gone full circle. And the
cooperation between the Protestant world
and the Roman Catholic
world will soon show where we are
heading. Yeah. And once that legislation
becomes propagated in a land where
church and straits should be separate,
the others are already geared to follow.
Yeah. They already ready and the whole
world will fall into this trap. May God
give us wisdom. Let's pray.
Heavenly Father, if this is the second
siege that we are
witnessing that it is preparing
itself and raising its head, then I pray
that you will give us
fortitude. Help us to make sure that our
lives are in harmony with your will and
then to stand under the bloodstained
banner of principal on which is
inscribed the commandments of God and
the faith of Jesus. Amen. Amen.
[Music]